I hope I can catch
before it's too late this gun probably
chewed right now it does
it's amazing what did you get that hair
though well this is that stuff oh yeah
this is why it works one day's oh no
this was a Bennett used it when he was
do when we did tabouli flea this was his
akhira
oh yes wasn't it yeah a tool see you sir
wait let that please the lion right no
no no no in tabouli flea he's lazy oh
yeah yeah so cool now you get to be a
cop woohoo the Popo sister and I was
gonna say uh either Jim or dead is it
possible because he's supposed to be
kind of like a toy cop just or walk in
like this is there we just put like a
black line like earlier sigh like he's
just okay perfect so pretty
uh yeah just put a black line and
Malcolm to have it show yeah it's all
very about sure that's who this is no
yeah no we can do that yeah you just
want your side and bring Malcolm you're
gonna be doing it just like you know I'm
going to cost ya you know Joey I'm going
to cuff you
yeah and then we'll like with your
voiceover later okay yeah so I just yeah
I don't see sister sir hello are you
telling me that guy dressed as an
officer with handcuffs and a guy dressed
like you just came out of leather bar
anyways gonna be taking sexually your
area very very I'll give it to go to the
blue ice bar yes off the Belmonts go oh
that's perfect actually
no absolutely perfect oh that's nice
yeah yeah oh that bad when I did a film
until we get to
Mike okay you got time I'm done done so
cool you your torture is just beginning
no your hands like yeah it goes yellow
oh that's that's our christened Duns for
now but we're guys she's gonna glamour
it up and gone look incredible you have
to go to the salon and tell me what the
Kirsten death yeah that's the Krista
death yeah okay here now come give me
debt to keep it running
not only does Malcolm look like a good
cop here look at his shoulder those are
oh yeah about that like nobody got these
are the Halloween store it's like I
guess they felt they had to make it look
a little different so nobody's confused
fucker who will be confused that this is
a cop anyway there you go just holding
creases and everything yeah I want to be
taken seriously
Oh Mart the mall cop that's what
badasses - are you okay I can Brian film
like you good sure it's recording
yeah now there'll be a ton on this one
I'm sure it's like two blank lines and
done right just Boop what does he make
you he's just getting back ready
I just had to take a seat to make it
official sis assistant you're gonna look
so purty nice actually
how's your soul fat coming it's coming
Java Greggy forgetting that nothing Ryan
target okay yeah it's it takes me
forever to grow facial hair so I just
shave every time I keep the gang at
trying to grow that mmm III at least
didn't notice it this time
yes assistant finding about this I was
telling Jim and Tamara I can't request
to do this movie forever oh and like I I
didn't get it cuz like it's not good
don't get me wrong but it's like it
never screamed terribly bad like there's
a lot of material for it so I was really
afraid to do it cuz I was just like I
don't know if I can get enough and right
finally I'm just like okay let's do
something like you know well what the
people want here and I think we got
another there's just enough crazy scenes
to get something out of it hmm have you
ever seen it yeah I remember seeing it
when I was like it'd be like 11 or -
yeah it's like that's part of the
problem it's like you said a kid's movie
or an adult movie is that you came in -
all right I was just really you sick you
have to be 15 or 16 otherwise you can't
you know what yeah but yeah it takes me
like two weeks to get shadow and then oh
sorry
okay what was it like after Earth that
you started growing it you're just like
ya know yeah you'll have to paint it you
know the solfege I got one growing it
were like what are we talking about
it's just takes forever
I said I at least see it yeah it's
starting to come in now hmm Jett my chin
out me
I keep talking dude that's always your
problem out for me keep talking just
stop talking no more of that good I'm a
toy cap I just saw the movie dolls you
ever see that no have you have you ever
seen it except from the ate like that
yeah the 80s oh yes it's amazing it's so
corny but it's hilarious it's like it's
really cool yeah and I saw a cabin fever
which is also amazing you see that one
that's that's vet that's like its own
kind of Evil Dead or something it's just
yeah it's just so in its own yeah hey
you're not a cop I've been wearing this
from once we know cuz I'm Aaron when
that movie came out like every critic
was like we don't know what the hell
this is this is nuts
and then I saw it and I think like if I
saw it like years ago I probably said
the same but now that I know more about
like the horror genre and just those
weird cliches and corniness and stuff
I'm like this is like friggin amazing I
love this very yeah that like is one of
two films he's done yeah anything real
so should you maybe like should I kind
of box the nose
um can you see I make a noise wipe it
off
come on this way wow you're right it's
like I came and tell us the week anymore
it's amazing let's see so what time can
I lose my oh yeah the focus is right
here yeah I should only and yep
was it uh not really no you got time so
do you like straight face like let's see
oh no you know what let's just go ahead
leave on the mouth okay so what face am
I gonna be making when I'm doing a guy
can't like that like like seriously like
mom oh yeah that that pretty much like
that I am a cop yes is it kind of like
that you know so yeah it's and we're
gonna dump over your dialog later so
yeah Ju yeah not even that just like
yeah there you go yeah I pretty much it
yeah and then devil boner blows you up I
don't know it's just ranting like the
most offense like not offensive it just
strangest obviously not good guy named
like devil Vader but also be hilarious
just to hear shouted against was a like
lady love embrace or something lady look
embrace and I'm double butter oh it's
gonna be in that bag
those are all good Oh y'all do that
better
I wasn't this one this one we turn into
the not co2 whatever might be better
that'd be hilarious laughs is this like
I'm officer not see the missing West
Side Story song officer Nazi oh yeah sir
are you all right time to be a cop put
on kappa did the other belt to count
looks like pajamas right now I I think
there's a thought this one in the bag
here too but that's like a big fake belt
yeah what Marilyn Tamra that for Ghost
Rider and she looked like a fire oh yeah
I'm going your mommy to work yeah Kaplow
this assistant I'm so big yeah sis just
landed there dude I saw I saw the
Cthulhu mask back there I'm like God I
need to bring that back it was so good I
know you guys put so much effort into
and there's like five seconds on screen
that's it yeah like okay not have found
another use for Cthulhu
there you go
we will find a way to get Optimus
Cthulhu in on us you're accruing appeal
get my big I think that should do it
Jake is he's gonna be shot kind of far
away so I should be fine okay
hey cool the only thing with me on
camera right now as I go yes
mm it's not quite a form
now that was earlier this is it looks it
looks beautiful and you know it no
actually no you look like you look like
mayor mascara from our mayor eyeshadow
from dark now you know I I'm a Batman
well you should have seen him earlier I
said he looked like a Super Saiyan Alice
Cooper yeah checking everything they're
a phallus Howard dress down for chopping
I have an idea that I got in my Simon
just an X or can I help you it's about
70 bucks I just the camera loves you so
if you can get Mike to say yes on that
Oh head is all Murray okay focus on the
event horizon Rob's eye juicy guardians
of the galaxy yes I did is that not the
most amazing movie ever made it really
is
have you seen it - hahaha yeah oh yeah
oh yeah I talked all right we talked
about you say yes he missed it oh yes I
love it so much and like it's a
feel-good movie with a talking raccoon
oh yes a sibling rivalry retrospect I
realized was really embarrassing cuz I'm
not sure I even talked about the
technical as much as though I was like
it's just so it's well-written
like a ten-year-old it we took like 20
minutes yeah we talked about but I don't
think we even said anything it just was
the same sort of like it was soaked
people really it was like a you know it
was totally like a schoolyard like kind
of thing like you're on the playground
during recess watch it to put it back
again yeah thanks play ball the clinics
are either like this is so awesome or
this is so stupid right this is so
stupid and awesome yeah no actually it's
I think it's still hovering at 90
percent I think yeah those that like
you're like it's stupid but awesome and
the few that didn't like it were just
like it's stupid hmm
yeah I'll show you the pit bay
she blows up and goes flying back yeah
that's like one of my favorite gosh I'm
glad we have again the de typecasting
retirees would you not addressing you do
your Dorothy or can you just act instead
again I guess you know it could be worse
it could be typecasting Malcolm hey
Malcolm can we put you the Dorothy
mortgage yeah another crazy person this
piece I prefer the crazy person well
that's gonna be the next episode
hyper fangirls coming out the end of
this episode yes this is me that next
was Princess Diaries - oh Christ
Oh tell me why you are in for a treat
okay yeah I don't know she saw the
sequel she saw Dee it's amazing it's
like amazingly bad am I so much fun I
likes that movie there must have been
some perfect teenage girl age that all
girls like like it cuz like yeah yeah I
am like exactly like this this perfect
age cuz every girl I know younger or
older than that age is like that movie
stupid yeah that was my car baby break
out the Diaries was oh god it's one of
those movies that I could put it at any
time
I'm sorry Tamra I attend I think is
guerrilla I think it's like our know I
think it's like our Ninja Turtles kind
of like we almost like yeah but my wife
loves Ninja Turtles
so that looks like a game a cartoon show
if you must have seen in reruns because
I'm like how's it possible you're four
years younger than me like I guess it's
still there was holdover but ya know
it's
it's still fucking around she's up
talking with yeah I'm talk about the
original ladies ok ok no I saw the
biggest insult right now I know there's
nothing do with the making of this or
anything I just want say this is
bullshit ok so I was out trying to look
for to buy princess iris to for this and
your collection I swear I've really
sherry I um but the but they had the
Ninja Turtles the first couple movies on
blu-ray
oh cool and I just I like check out the
box cover so I look on the back the
costumes that they have are obviously
from the third one and like the
conscience in the first film are amazing
yeah incredible and they just like I
don't just get something of them from
one of the movies so they obviously just
grab images from the third one and put
them on there and then the second one
they do things for your psycho moisture
up its the costumes from the third movie
I'm like fuck you guys it's like those
guys right before everybody let's go
look at like oh man we've come a long
ways but at least the third movie had a
stabilizing Casey Jones perform he was
awesome too
he was the only awesome thing that movie
I'm like oh yeah like but I want three
alright I have my hopes up just because
of that I'm just like okay maybe won't
be that bad because freakin Casey
Jones's and like I'm adding with Casey
Jones's sauce oh yes have you seen it
yellow there no idea we saw in the
theater it's it's really really we were
here that we were hitting that age to
where it's like we were kind of like to
four teenage mutant and I need to be
like 15 yeah we work at yeah and if
you're kind of giving her my baby get
over this whatever it's still kind of
got us and had it been like the first
film I probably wouldn't have been
embarrassed but about halfway middle is
really I'm like I think this is aimed
squarely at 10 year old that's 10 year
olds who have been traveling since when
it's time there is
another no job beaten um mentally abused
by their parents and/or friends um and
anything what I have on top of it is I
think we've hit the bedrock cuz when it
started we were like seven so so that we
still lived in the skelton than even the
nostalgia couldn't it just gonna save it
it's so bad it's so bad and then we were
high too because we thought it was gonna
be like turtles in time the freaking
arcade game that was our we're like you
know then what go back in time to
dinosaurs it go right whistles I'm sure
they have the fun job yeah it's like
we're back in time to a cheap set a few
nickel back into right sitcom of
dinosaurs this is a crossover that was
been actually yeah much better
I mean it doesn't episode so
occasionally sure the Michael Bay
produced film can be better than turtles
in time
mmm that is my any stretch but that's
the only I they'll be they have over
different rate yeah yeah be better than
turtles in time just give up good point
hmm this is a cartoon show then hit
Pizza monsters in it right like I can be
Khmer that they're like a low yeah in I
need a chair somehow honey do a Malcolm
you oh yeah well do that is what happens
oh yeah we're gonna do be doing a comic
book show as well as the game show so we
were looking for comments to put up as
kind of a background someone on some of
is in my older x-men Wow yeah I can tell
you right now that if I can steal this I
was where did you get these from Mike
Adam but Sonny these are some of these
things I haven't seen like in years yeah
chunks in my comic collection or wall
gone but like you know stuff like and
the 80s and early 90s like oh man
yeah this is amazing yeah it's like a
new condition what was what oh yeah now
it's
it's changed with your finger and I said
we could use himself that's cool Wow I
don't know this comic infinity babe well
you have any idea uh that's infinity
Crusade hmm
squeeze she-hulk Fantastic Four
spider-man x-men yeah what is that
just Thanos rogue Silver Surfer
something to do with a no so is this
spider
yeah spider-man yeah hurry no all right
how do you name everyone except the I
made it
I had read this shit in 20 years I told
you to read comics but you wouldn't
listen to me oh man so it's gonna be
like a background like a background wall
Oh God
next year am i are you doing this for a
green screen yes you're gonna hang these
things up assuming I need green it may
actually hang it up I know I'm gonna be
Oz I was like when I came in I was just
like oh that right yeah like I kept
going to God who does work this actually
reminds me of my friend Moe chocolate he
has a Walking Dead comic background on
his videos it's pretty interesting
rob has unlocked the secret oh you know
this took me forever because I littered
well this is this came up 193 I really
didn't read infinity Crusade that much I
was into this earlier um I was born in
1979 all right oh um no I was kidding
yeah and oh my god all my friends who
liked comics oh we moved oh this is me
by my lonesome rose again um but I think
this character is only in this one and
Wow maybe Doug no no no no
it hit me when I cruise back
do you know who this is no Phoenix its
is Marvel no it's like war yeah this is
how I know it is the same and it's not
mrs. war like it's like Morris open
though Rogan fine yeah you know you
could know that he's gonna ruin the
mission get the spotlight blocks it's
something warlock created its third
cosmic round right now people in the
comments are like a god damn it it's
this person no it's the embodiment of
the good side of warlock it's like whoa
it's good side and I think she's called
like the goddess of something I think
it's the goddess of something or just
the goddess was it so it's one of those
entities like Phoenix or like I think oh
god it's been so long for was it like it
got a bunch of infinity cubes or
something together and he created a good
side of himself that was the embodiment
of all his goodness and I believe she's
called the goddess and I she's like the
central character in that series hmm but
like as I said I haven't seen that since
94 95 like so I'm sure I'm gonna get
hell in the comic packaging I know but
does past this is past the point when I
was reading comics really religiously so
pretty much I pretty much I stopped
reading comics religiously when I moved
and that was in 1992 oh okay she has two
claims in here
the redemptoris and very good rod yes I
am the goddess yes oh yes yes
still got it it was Barry Singh Lee slow
but still get it just blow off the
barrel huh I should have read more back
in the cleaver the artist named the does
the weird anatomy in the comics the
uh-oh Rob Liefeld said his art
I don't think so I don't think so all I
know about him is what Lewis says and
it's not good things
oh no they're now the artwork seems very
reasonable Ozzie those are my fans I
think you would know yeah yeah yeah
honey what I've heard is there you go
there's Drax and Gamora in there oh wow
but even says I'll be the chance to
fight for what you for what is right and
just Gamora nice no I mean these series
I mean oh really this sort of stuff is
what got me right there I'll just cooked
me about Marvel Comics and and then
because you get all of these teams
together and they would go on adventures
and it would take place over the course
of their own comics as well right then
they would come back you know spider-man
would come back and then deal with his
life again and it would be always
referencing I mean the universe was just
huge and that's what the movies trying
yeah love love them yeah I'll be like
until 2020 before we see the Guardian
this is where we're I don't know which
yeah infinity we're heading towards but
I mean you got the gauntlet there's
infinity for saying yeah the infinitum
or to see where Marvel's realize I think
it's gonna be the enemy downside yeah
you got like the infinity war kind of
sorry yeah they do they put on it's
gonna be awesome yeah matter which one
they do they're all awesome right this
one was a little later so I wasn't as
aware of it but I can't wait for that
Avengers crossover though 2020 yeah yeah
I just want to see The Guardian I just
want to see like guardians of the galaxy
crash of their marble feel right just
they should become like a big sort of
in-joke like right you singing out doing
their thing show up occasionally just
party crashers yeah Doug Phoenix right
yeah this that Phoenix uh not even I met
down Oh Louise here it's for goddess the
goddess her armor is there like lay
before him I had to dig deep
dig deep into the childhood must retain
some slight semblance of cred yeah yeah
okay this is exactly this is Doug's
office we it's a shot at you want to
give you possibly this trio Dante's cool
we get there real fast while you two do
it so creepy you're gonna what does the
right guy after the Henry thing I know
you're pretty good so go ahead put that
on you guys are going to be right there
so for now because I know you gotta
leave early urchins won't have a bright
have you over here little bit this way
but pretty much what is it some in the
scene like Chris and Texas going over
this he says he'll make it this right
I'm you know pinned to the ground by a
bunch of naked Barbies or deformed had
knives for hands and they're naked and
they're tying me up and I'm supposed to
be there helpless and you know mountains
like babies like yeah he's like it
should I question those little this is
very strange it's like look just do what
he wants and you know of course don't
ask any questions that we just get to
shove you just watching like yeah sorta
yeah and then they'll be like you know
all right so we ready to roll and you're
ready to start rolling it just like
rolling no like really
but he took your unless so how do you do
these thanks dude as I am really pbn
just with putting on net for all you
guys is really the best actor of all
time I just never knew it Joe Dante I
really liked his movies and I think he's
he seems like a really cool guy I don't
know why I'm being so it's just a weird
CA then it's like you directed it so
it's like yeah and all all for graphs
thing right here what number the one
thing I found out uh I really didn't
know anybody some research on okay how
many hit films is your Dante directed
yes yeah bone or five kids yeah like
that made money did really well
Ravi zero no no or it omelets
okay grand and nothing else
it's really weird why you're not like
along as Louise bozo get up I'm like yes
he says like no hands
I'm fine with that I think that one was
just such a huge hit you know that yeah
maybe I'll do it
use others make their money back I don't
it's really you know that they might you
know everything he could advertising
stuff but yeah it's like I'm just
watching like wow that's really strange
am I looking at her yeah Brea Bremen
sure she is yeah hi 16 year old Kirsten
Dunst
she's a really good actress they were
just get nor spider-man um Lacey uh
didn't you do Marie Antoinette yeah
though she wasn't very good he's got
everything else though should have a
tienen naked seems pretty nice Kirsten
right yeah in that case you can't just I
don't you think I remember yeah I'm good
baby
okay so um can we bros let's see alright
so I'll just do Malcolm's line here so
we'll have you sir with the creepy what
going I'll say okay are we ready to
start rolling mr. Dante and you just go
rolling okay do I just look how--look
often no wait okay he's gonna be down
here - oh hey no tying her so see you
again yeah HR BAC real fast - yeah at
the AC
right he feels great in here be happy
that we don't have klieg light right oh
man
presents and nice and nice and cool yeah
you're gonna do an audition and your age
you want you to redo your audition tape
um yeah well I record from home like
most of all myself or talent does and
this one was four stars and um with a Z
so stuff yes stars and apparently they
want me to sound even more Street yeah
urban yeah yeah that's the word I can
show you I can't even show you the email
it's pretty hilarious tart what it is
huh start what it is melon
yeah no it's like yeah it's pretty
straightforward but they just want it to
be high energy but Arvind yeah but urban
high energy and I was in her yeah I'm
like okay so do you want you know Samuel
Jackson or do you want the West Side of
Chicago
you gotta give me some kind of some kind
of scale oh so I'm just like okay I get
you creep on Jim alright all that look
okay are we ready to start rolling mr.
Dante what just like that that's good
alright good hold it okay are we ready
to start rolling mr. Dante really oh
okay now we could add to what's really
sad is that Joe Dante did a um he did a
Looney Tunes movie
I want it was called back in action I
take all mone tunes back in action those
huh and like it's you know it's got its
probs and everything but it's it's
Looney Tunes it's like cool they they're
doing is going to not being as Looney
tune oh I was gonna say so like it came
out like nobody saw it and there's a lot
of Chris this is about it's okay I get
the criticism it's like okay there's a
lot of problems but then like when space
gia came out everybody was like oh yeah
no this is the Looney tune these are the
guys who grew up with us like no fuck
that shit
let's show the green spring class yeah I
thought those were like old props when
she had them on in the studio but these
are great Photoshop something into hyper
fangirl space what is she looking at did
you just put like two just haven't fully
white Eva to a black Dawn's which is
just looking she's not nothing yeah yeah
jinkies what excuse me 820 Scooby's next
man what's this see Elliot Oh play yeah
it's a big fan of LA I think it's here
yeah here it is
right okay yeah okay so so if I don't
story about this guy might give a little
bit of shout out there's a video store
called family video that I go to it's
like one only rental stores left yeah so
they're all the time I'll say I went to
Best Buy I want to deserve videos thrown
away there they weren't there and so
finally went to the family video and
they had this but it was rented out I
just went out there it just said look I
need this for a prop can I come here all
the time can I just borrow this just for
the day and she's like yeah sure so
thank you family video that's very nice
be sponsor so much frost yep
sponsored by fat video I still feel like
good girls like I'll even work here
what she live of the magic yeah I'm
curious about family video it's like
they've got to be a cover for something
it's like not still around
right turns out Walter White runs it
oh no it's not talked about this I know
need beside blockbusters what was the
other big one
Hollywood Vidya Hollywood video and
those are the big three yeah yeah thanks
for family videos just in the Midwest
honestly scores Tamara that this'll this
is gonna be really tricky to get you
know what I'm pretty sure it can suck it
this is gonna be really itself I'm
quitting maybe can she can stand up for
the day you could be asleep on your
couch in the living room uh yeah it's
funnier in creepier this way uh maybe
she can be in front of the window um I
think I can get this C starts up really
close ah let's do a dick turn the light
a little that way pork like that ah I
see
maybe then as you try to get on her yeah
hope you have a black bland it was okay
good sir pointed this way death by it
wait he said he's good
thank you yeah
Shuki coasters ironically reflection
even though the boxes are covered
thank you yes okay miss missing G right
yes